hi welcome to GameSpot daily where we
cover six of the hottest news stories in
the gaming industry and about 30 minutes
for less or we have to listen to our
bosses complaining about how how dope we
are yeah we can go over 30 minutes as
long as we want
yes that good morning everybody like we
do have to wrap this up in 30 minutes or
less because there is a stream going on
at 11:30 so stick around for that
today's gonna be playing pub G ooh it's
gonna be playing on the new savage man
he's gonna play in the new savage map
and there's gonna be some code giveaway
so you can jump into the savage map that
is actually one of our stories today but
it's not our first yes I know that we do
have to do a little housekeeping here
real quick this is not Cali play game
I'm not going to despite what the lower
third says I've totally messed up and I
didn't change the lower thirds this is
actually Sam light hammer hey guys here
at game Sam does a lot of things on the
social team she also gets on a lot of
streams Kelly is out on assignment today
so that is why she's not here with me as
she usually is but we have Sam here in
her stead for the day yes
okay so we'll kick it off with a big
story the first big story that we got
first off before before we get into the
story I'm sorry I know I know you are
yahooza 6 is out today so get it please
yes we had to give you your moment yes
that is that is my moment but as you can
tell from prior to the stream before
joining us where our lead story is Dark
Souls related so that is what we will
give to you burst gotcha well ok guys so
if you are excited for the Dark Souls
remaster on switch it's good it's
delayed now it's pretty sad it was
supposed to come out on May 25th on the
ps4 Xbox one and the PC versions but
it's not to lead to 2018 ok the switch
version only so sorry yeah so the
Nintendo switch version of Dark Souls
remastered is not going to be releasing
on May 25th the remastered but it is
gonna be on other things yes it will
come out on it will still come out on PC
Xbox one and ps4 on May 25th so
the switch version is set to release in
the summer of 2018 no specific release
date but as that is the release window
for the switch version of Dark Souls
remastered so you won't be able to play
on the go any time soon
well summer is pretty soon yeah time
goes by fast once you get to my age time
is just like rolls is gone that also
includes the solaire of astora amiibo of
course you wouldn't want to buy the
amiibo without the game or not having
the game so that is for them to just
like give the amiibo early and be like
alright guys come and no yes trust me
you got the amiibo so it's on the way
and then it never comes everybody has
the amiibo they get really mad but that
amiibos dope because it does a praise
the Sun if you already cool if y'all
into the Dark Souls like I kind of am
mmm it's cute yes so the reason for the
delay has not been stated would you want
to pull up some b-roll well my mouth
sorry we actually do have some footage
here of Dark Souls let's switch so it is
playable we know it exists yeah it's a
touch they're not trying to snake us so
yea though so the reason why it's been
delayed has not been stated and I
imagine that's just mainly because of
like refinements and making sure you
ship a like a perfectly fine version of
the game yeah that's understandable but
again they haven't said exactly why it's
been delayed now a couple technical
details for the switch version is that
when it's docked it'll play it'll be at
1080p running up to 30 FPS natl not
locked but but capped at 30fps so that's
a important distinction to make it's
different than the other versions in
that way yeah because they had the dark
dark souls remastered on the other
consoles have some specific are higher
higher resolutions and better frame
rates but this is the Nintendo switch
yeah so but when you take it on the go
portable like you are seeing right here
it'll run 720p there up to 30 FPS which
is just pretty dope could you scroll
back up oh sorry sorry it's all good
we're us Sam this is Sam's first time
officially on the show yes i-i've only
I've done this once before you guys saw
knew that we were doing this and so I'm
a bit rusty here it's all right this is
Sam's first time so take it easy on her
but yes Dark Souls on switch you know so
that's that's what's up if you're gonna
praise the Sun you praise it this summer
ooh a sun's out guns out so yeah the
full list of changes for Dark Souls
remastered is on gamespot.com so you can
get all that information there the one
of the cool things about the remastered
version is that you supports up to 6
players online instead of 4 players from
the original version so that's pretty
dope and other changes like a new
bonfire and different controls for
selecting and using items so there's
technical refinements on the on the
control front as well as the visual
front so Dark Souls remastered is
looking pretty dope I'm I want to get
into this because I played the pc
version pc version was rough was it wait
yeah when when did you play it this is
like 2012 that came out I think 2011
yeah I might be tripping maybe - no it's
okay you're like an old man Michael you
know it's okay if you don't remember the
exact time frame but I did play okay
yeah so you're excited to get back into
it
mm-hmm I don't I don't know if I'll be
picking up Dark Souls I don't have them
about that life like it's it's a rough
life to be a Dark Souls fan it is
learned I mean it's just it's the you
know it's like not even that the game is
that intimidating because I know that
there's like this everybody says the
Dark Souls is like the equivalent of
it's a hard game right that's like what
it's always used as a comparison and I
don't think I'm intimidated by the
gameplay I just know it's super grindy
and it's basically like just figuring
out patterns it's just like a pattern
puzzle fighting easier said than done
easier said than done
easier said than otherwise words of Eric
Tay he says get good get good he's our
resident I don't I just don't believe my
ability to care so I'm just kidding I'm
just kidding that's one of them I might
have to pick it up though because I have
I am really into my switch and I just
you know always knew something new to
play yes which was dope
intense games like Dark Souls coming to
switch it looks good for the platform it
does so that's exciting but you're gonna
have to wait a little again the story of
today is that Dark Souls remastered for
the switch switch only is delayed till
summer of this year but all the other
versions still May 28 2015 was like wait
are they all getting pushed back I got I
got myself oh man something I am
actually genuinely very excited about is
the pub gia savage map is back you can
play it again today and tomorrow mm-hmm
the testing they had testing I was not I
don't think last week but the week
before for the savage map yes I took a
part of that beta and I was very excited
it's a smaller map it's about half the
size of the original and it's just uh
it's faster circle closes and quicker
there's hot loot and you're forced into
these very close combat fights right
away
so in this second beta they are going to
be adding new areas
there's the by n Grove by Bonnie on
Bonnie on and the abandoned quarry yes
I'm in the middle of map there's a dock
in the southeast section which features
a tower crane and two large ships and
those images are all in the article
agent T's take a look at that yeah they
did tease some of these new areas of the
map in the first beta you could tell
that it was not finished of course you
could really tell even all the little
huts and everything were really barren
there was nothing inside them but the
loo and I don't know if that's like
something that they're going to change
but you could tell that there was a lot
more to come so I'm really excited to
jump back in there and see some of the
new new areas that they are going to
have available another change that
they're implementing is the Blue Zone
now calculates and adjust its waiting
time based on the number of players left
alive so yeah it's gonna be different if
I recall correctly I think h1z1 did
something does something similar to that
where instead of a fixed a fixed time
frame in which the blue deadly zone
closes in it's relative to the amount of
players so that's
nice little change of pace but when
things is intense I'm not really I'm
just paying attention to whether or not
it's closing in on me
but this is a slight change so if
everyone if everyone just chilling out
hanging out not wanting to pull up and
shoot you down pretty much chill for a
little while but yeah that's there's no
specifics on the the way in which it's
calculated and when it moves so that's
kind of a mystery just knowing that they
have changed the way in which it does
move so that's that is something that is
different about this round of testing
for codename savage definitely another
thing is that they're doing differently
as the resident is no smaller and lasts
for less time I think it's because the
red zones pretty big given the size of
the map in the first run and it was
really scary I think they should just
get rid of the red zone altogether
that's just what I you know what I
I agree with you I've only been killed
by the red zone once and it felt really
stupid when I got killed by the red zone
because I hadn't so many times before I
was like this red zone cilium yeah sorry
then you die like that one out of a
hundred times and you're like wow really
really yeah I've always like hesitant
like hey let's no no let's stay inside
let's not go outside but then Nick who
you can see here in the bottom left he's
always like I'm just gonna drive through
it doesn't matter we're not gonna get
hit every time he does that we don't get
hit I'm just like okay okay now I'm less
a little less anxious to get into the
red zone but I time I swear I was
playing with Jake if it was me and Nick
and Jake we're playing in the original
map and we were in the red zone by the
clip so there was no we couldn't get
into a building yeah there's nothing so
weird across her finger said oh man
let's let's make sure we don't get hit
by this so Jake was crawling I was gonna
go rez him so as I was running up to him
a bomb drop straight up on his body and
I saw my friend die right before my eyes
so you have personal reasons to want to
get rid of this seems like it's over no
more red zones please I saw that I saw
the worst of it I don't want to see that
again
so well they're smaller and this
new ones so I don't think we're gonna
see the goodbye to the red zone anytime
soon but they will be smaller in the
second beta and other change they're
making as boats will spawn less author
on the map while seaside towns will see
them more consistently so that makes
sense I mean boats are supposed to be
where boats go I guess sure weather now
changes more dynamically throughout the
match instead of just the previous one
and another thing that they're fixing is
an issue with footsteps making the wrong
sound has been resolved I hadn't noticed
that but I'm happy to hear that that
problem has been eradicated because that
seems not fair imagine if like footsteps
were making the sound of like rustling
of the of the bushes or something like
that's weird it just seems it just seems
oh yeah okay yeah I guess so I'm just
not good enough for footsteps are very
important I'm well aware of the effect
of footsteps in these games really
important extremely so anyway yeah if
you guys are willing if you guys are
wanting to take a part of the beta for
the new savage map now it's your time
today and tomorrow we actually have a
giveaway on the site for beta codes
going Yes No
so if you're watching this you know
those are still available yes
and again like I said at the beginning
of this this dream we will be streaming
pubsey codename savage right after the
show yes and teh your boy Kuya tame will
be giving out some coats on that scream
so I don't know who else is on that but
stick around because it's gonna be fun
it's always fun it's always fun alright
we're gonna get into something a little
bit more meaty here that kind of hits
close to me because I am a big Mass
Effect fan I did not know this about you
oh yeah I mean everybody knows your big
Yakuza fan and persona and a persona fan
so this bears it's tight but all right
I'm aspect is also one of the
franchise's that I deeply you have a lot
of us here to deeply love yeah just
shake but uh Andromeda to say the least
was a disappointment for us mmm oh man
most people and Bioware's GM Casey
Hudson has talked about come out and
talk about mass effects
Mass Effect Andromeda is lack of DLC
and the focus on anthem mm-hmm so how it
altered their perspective in a big way
yes how they approach games and
developing DLC real quick Casey Hudson
is he's a he's a big big name in terms
of Bioware's history he was the director
of the original Star Wars Knights of the
Old Republic which is one of my favorite
games of all time and he was also kind
of he was also a big lead for the mass
effect the original Mass Effect trilogy
then he had left in he had left after
Mass Effect 3 and then he came back to
Bioware in 2017 after the release of
Andromeda two kind of more or less
helped write the ship over at Bioware
but yes he has come out and talked about
why there hasn't been Mass Effect DLC
and how that's affected anthem which is
the next project from Bioware so hmm
want to hit that hot b-roll of anthem
real quick and we're gonna give you some
some quotes directly from Casey Hudson
himself yes so he said that being unable
to deliver that though he said that
being unable to deliver was as
frustrating for them as it was for the
players so verbatim said that that
experience ultimately became a defining
moment in refocusing Bioware's mission
we need to delight players with new
experiences in innovation but we must
stay focused on the importance of the
world character and storytelling
elements that players expect from our
games and our games must be designed to
continue delivering new stories and
experiences in an ongoing relationship
with players in worlds we're evolving
together you want to get the second yeah
I mean it's interesting because I mean
looking at hearing that and then looking
at the second part of him or thinking
about the second part of his blog post
it seems like they're taking a lot of
that sentiment and trying to make that
an important part of developing anthem
he goes on to say it's in that spirit
that we are working through production
on anthem a game designed to create a
whole new world of story and character
that you can experience with friends to
an ongoing series of adventures it will
be unlike anything you've played but it
will we will do it right it will feel
very distinctly Bioware so it seems like
the overarching thing here is is that
they want to take the lessons that they
learned from their experience with Mass
Effect Andromeda and really consider
consider those in the development of
anthem yeah
and I also believe that you know for
Bioware it makes sense for them to not
go back to something that more or less
didn't hit with fans right instead of
trying to do DLC or resurrect Mass
Effect Andromeda with Story DLC like we
still don't know what happened with the
Quarian ship and in Mass Effect
Andromeda did they make it to Andromeda
or or not like there's people so care
yeah yeah yeah that's another things
like I guess I kind of do even though
I'm not too big on Andromeda mm-hmm but
the fact that they're saying you know
instead of doing DLC for this game that
is more or less in the past now we're
going to focus all our efforts on this
new game and making sure that it's up to
our standards unlike this past game it's
released it's kind of cool that they've
decided to come out and talk about that
and talk about anthem because I know
they have been kind of quiet for a while
and so I think it was them trying to
reassure people who are waiting and
watching you know just get and give them
a little reassurance that they're
they're trying to make a good product
yes so that's kind of cool
uh yeah I would it's it's what I would
expect and Casey Hudson I he's like one
of my favorite names in the devel and
game development mhm
so I more or less trust what he has to
say I mean he made some of my favorite
games of all time and you know I'm I
don't know if I'm sold on the concept of
anthem being this like destiny esque
type of game with a little bit more RPG
elements but I'm willing to look into it
and keep my eye on anthem mm-hmm so
because Bioware I think Bioware still
has life in them obviously because
they're still a big project they're
still there by where yeah so anthem is
supposed to what kind of it was supposed
to said - it's said to have been
released in
18 but yeah word on the street is now
that's coming in 2019 yeah that's not
much of a surprise yeah they've decided
to announce that really early in the
year probably to just like be
transparent and not because they know
January from the beginning people are
building a pipe around the games they
know that are coming up this year and I
think they want to probably avoid a
situation where people were building a
lot of hype for anthem and then all of a
sudden it was gonna be like a no I'm
sorry next year but like in June you
know that would have been not a great
scenario for the scenario for them yeah
tempering expectations I suppose so yeah
so just being real being transparent I
wonder if we'll get any little teasers
at e3 I'm sure I wonder I hope that they
have something to show off you know even
if they even if the release window
hasn't changed you be cool to see
something new yeah I know anthem was
revealed at e3 2017 so I would expect to
see a little bit more III this year
which is right around the corner time is
fast yeah
and this show has to move faster because
we are we're taking our time here but
well you know we took a little time [ __ ]
G and with anthem they're important
topics you know yeah we spend our time
on the important topic topics and we're
gonna blaze through this one is here
yeah cliffy B claimed that epic is
hiring away members of his studio oh
snap so close yeah cleave B took to
Twitter to just state his case or
whatever and saying that hey epic games
could you please stop trying to hire
away my team we just launched radical
heights on Yui for Unreal Engine 4 and
I'm really happy about how it's doing
Lozinski also said that there's room at
the resume at this genre for more more
than a few games shake my head or s mhm
and we have plenty of ways to make it
our own but they may never see the light
of day if epic keeps doing this Twitter
salt yeah there's some Twitter salty
juice on Twitter yeah and there was
there's more to this epic decline to
make any statements of to GameSpot and
no request for comment though boss key
programmer William
responded directly to cliffie bees tweet
by saying with all due respect assuming
that epic is one of them one starting
contact poaching is a bit presumptuous
we all had our own reasons for making
the choice to leave boskie productions
for epic and act to act like we are
commodities being stolen is a bit
hurtful
yeah and it's a bit ridiculous yeah and
continue to say we are people first and
foremost of course because people are
people individuals making individual
choices based on what's best for them
shocker
I haven't played radical heights but I
know you guys don't stream last week or
at least era can bend it and what have
you given it a shot I have given a shot
babe I'm known as the Battle Royale
okay with all due respect I will I will
not but I'm more or less known as the
Battle Royale expert in the office which
isn't saying much father have battle
royale yeah sure that's a nice way to
put it
they got a nickname for Michael here and
we have nicknames for all of us in here
and but I am have reviewed pubsey muted
h1z1 and reviewed fortnight battle
royale and put some time into radical
Heights and I mean it's to say it's an
extreme early access it's an extreme
early access so there's no ladies in the
game they're working on it and think
apparently it's a really weird bizarre
thing but yeah so the story of the day I
guess is that there's some drama around
Twitter that we are not going to get
involved in but we will let you know
that it's happening it's that that's out
there but yeah Chloe B isn't like any
any old developer he is one of the key
minds behind the Unreal series and also
one of the one of the producers of the
Gears of War franchise so he's not he
and nobody but again this yes this is a
bit out of line I suppose I would say
okay so on that note we actually this is
a heavy story as well oh boy yeah oh man
God of War is almost out but there are
some things we're still unraveling about
God of War including the fact that the
game um
didn't have Kratos his son at Reyes yes
now God Juarez I've been following has
received high critical praise with a lot
of credit going around to the father-son
dynamic between creo sand at Reyes
because that is the the crux of God of
War story and at one point Sony
suggested that uh traces were all be
reduced or cut altogether due to the
development cost of implementing him
that is yeah that's that's huge this is
a and director Cory Baro log told
GameSpot that this would have totally
changed the game's dynamic which is to
say the least yeah I mean it would be
like removing the the second most
important character of the entire arc of
the story yeah of course
so you want to read this quote from Cory
Barra log that he told us yes it would
have been very different the early phase
when they told me man this was might be
too hard too expensive and were already
looking at so many challenges it's maybe
too much when I went back and said
alright fine if it's not with the Tres
what would it be and it would have been
a very very different game the
comparison I made was all right it's
gonna be all is lost with Robert Redford
it's gonna be one character who talks to
himself occasionally but generally it
will be very silent and everyone will be
talking in Old Norse so that won't
understand anything so he won't
understand anything anyone saying sorry
for the hang-ups there he was he he was
saying in his own voice it was hard to
like mimic that but basically we would
have seen a story where Kratos was
essentially just not talking to anybody
yeah he would so if you're not familiar
he had the comparison to all his lost
with Robert Redford which is a 2013
movie just if you consider how old
Robert Redford is it's a miracle that
he's still acting yeah this is true but
yeah that was I'm lost at seeing I'm
trying to find my way and I'm all alone
so this would have been a very different
game obviously if Kratos was on his own
trying to not get get unlost yes in the
scandal yeah and the Norse world so yeah
yeah it probably would have been more
reminiscent of an old regatta war game
in some ways because some of the things
that made this god of war so
groundbreaking for the series at least
is that the story was so unexpectedly
deep and emotional right it got got
people in their fields from what I hear
I haven't gotten to play Conte the new
god of war but what I did read our
review watched I've heard what
everybody's had to say and it seems like
this game has gotten people getting
people in their fields yeah
so yeah I definitely think now I have
played some god of war myself mm-hmm as
I've alluded to many times before on the
show but yeah the the father-son dynamic
in this game works extremely well I mean
whether or not you sympathize with
Kratos is a different thing given his
his shitty history throughout the Gulf
Wars trilogy the original trilogy
Michael hire thrown Kratos no bones yeah
definitely not but yeah this is this is
the this is kind of if you look at all
the all the reviews it's kind of like
this is this is an accomplishment and
storytelling being able to handle this
very hard in like figure of who's just
been like fighting and killing monsters
and gods his whole life and then trying
to teach a son the ways in which he
should survive and handle himself that
that is an accomplishment to know that
that may have not been the initial
vision or that could have not happened
at all is pretty crazy to me definitely
the fact that Sony was willing to say
okay we're gonna give you the budget and
the time to create this says a lot about
you know trusting developers and seeing
their whole vision through because again
like like what he's what we got out of
the story is that you know budget
constraints could have cut an important
character and the story altogether
yeah I don't know what's going on with
what the inner workings and Sony are
like but you know their choices produced
some pretty great games yeah so I would
agree I never regret buying my place - I
never I've never regret purchasing a
PlayStation I I love my ps4 and I'm
really excited to get my hands on this
game in to speak to what we were saying
about the addition of atreya s-- Rob
Davis who is the lead designer or Rob
Davy's I'm not sure how to pronounce his
last name but the he's a lead level
designer and he opened up about the
gameplay and story telling opportunities
that Reyes added saying that actually
like having a tray us be an expert in
Norse language and mythology is awesome
because you can do a whole other set of
design based on what at Reyes is an
expert in that Kratos is sort of not
yeah and so it just opened up more
gameplay and storytelling opportunities
which was pretty cool yeah so gamespot
us will have a for the full interview we
have a story right now of focusing
particularly on the the battle to get at
Reyes in God of War but we will have a
full interview feature with Cordy bar
log and Davis on the on the God of War
so that will be coming to the site in
the future so stay tuned for that and
also we have a review that's on the site
if you are curious to hear what Peter
Brown had to say oh yeah and he had a
lot of good things to say about it yes
now the game is set to release on Friday
April 20th yes so it's not out yet but
everyone's been talking about it soon
alright so this is our final story of
the day something I'm very excited for
it well unless you're in Japan oh yeah a
second Mega Drive the Genesis many has
been revealed and it will include many
classic games yes
so I love me some old games yeah all
games are cool I reviewed this Ness
classic I like that I like these dude
you did review this Ness classic I do a
lot of things out here how do you so so
as the the dude who reviewed this Ness
classic how do you feel about this Mega
Drive news this mini mega drive it's
cool I kind of I can't say that I am
surprised that Sega wants in on the
retro Hardware crazy
yes but yet so during Sega fests 2018
which happened Friday last week so this
isn't like completely like that but I
thought we'd throw this in there since
we had not talked about it yet is that
they revealed that make it mega drive
Mini which is a tentative title is
actually coming out in Japan though yeah
that means soon for us is it or never
it's one of the other we have
tells on whether or not it's coming to
North America or anything yeah it means
soon in a few years or Never
okay yeah that's sure if you want to
cover all of your bases that's it I
guess that's true I'm gonna I'm gonna
put all my eggs in the basket of soon
I'm hoping soon okay I want to want to
pull up the the tweet from Sega of Japan
yeah well I mean can you read this
because I cannot well no well so this is
what they do a table they were they had
a live stream in which they revealed it
was all in Japanese so I didn't get to
understand it but they did tweet this
out there is a translation that roughly
reads - could you pull up the quote
scroll down the the tweet roughly
translates to Mega Drive Mini tentative
announced for 2018 so it's this year
while reproducing the design of Mega
Drive released in 1988 thirty years ago
it results in about the size of a
quarter of the original Mega Drive and
you can join me you can enjoy it by just
connecting to your TV details details
such as a specific release date and the
final title will be announced at a later
date hmm
Sega Sega that's also had a lot of other
news that came out to Lake last week and
we're not gonna bring this story up but
you know shouldn't me wanted to yeah
some other cool things happened during
that whole thing so this was just one of
little tidbits that came out that were
excited for yeah man 30th anniversary of
the Mega Drive also known as Genesis
here in North America
that's 1988 man I was even born by then
yeah me neither
two years show yeah so that's our last
story of the day that the Mega Drive
Mini is coming out in Japan this year
but who knows when we're getting in
North America and we have to wrap up the
show because it's 11:30 and Tay or 11:31
running late yeah so Tay is probably
getting ready for to play some pub G so
stick around for that for some also he's
gonna be gaming away codes to test the
new map yes yeah Oh G Xbox games are out
on new oh gee Xbox games are back up at
now on Xbox one I saw saundra playing
Panzer Dragoon Orta and it looks crispy
as hell and I gotta say I like that word
crispy it looks pretty yep new episode
of steam Punk's our friends in Australia
just McDonnell Edmund Tran that is their
new show so there's new episode out on
site so you can check that out yes again
August 6 is out today
mmm-hmm hop on that and yes cigarette
for the stream yep
thank you Michael from the bottom of my
heart for thank you for having me up on
today and tomorrow Callie she'll resume
yeah so thank you to Matt Padgett Tony
Wilson for helping us get ready in the
morning thank you to Eric TAFE for
helping and produce a show Emily consi
also helps produce the show so thank you
very much and thank you all for sticking
around chillin with us talking about all
the news we have fun doing this and we
hope that you have fun as well any last
word Sam I'm gonna go try to figure out
how I can play pub G right now all right
well peace out bye guys have a good
morning
you